[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, welcome
all to the ninth lecture
series in our fall series,
God and Computers--
Minds, Machines,
and Metaphysics.
I welcome you all, and
specifically the students
who are at the end
of the term and have,
certainly, a lot of
other things to do.
Welcome here.
For all people who
want to discuss
a little bit beyond the question
sessions we have tonight--
and usually after
the question series--
on Monday, December 7th,
at Harvard Divinity School
at 12 o'clock, Harvey Cox and me
run, again, a discussion group
on this lecture series.
12 o'clock, Harvard
Divinity School on Monday.
So for all people who want
to talk about issues which
go a little bit
beyond what we can
answer in this lecture series.
So far, we had two
different paragraphs
in this lecture series.
The first four lectures
in the series dealt with,
what does it mean to be human?
What is the so-called
human factor?
The second lecture-- the second
part of the lecture series,
then the next four lectures
presented case studies
from a Catholic, a Jewish, a
Hindu, and Buddhist perspective
on how scientists deal
with existential issues
within and outside
of their research.
And the last two
lectures, we have today
and next Wednesday are
lectures dealing now
going back to computer
science, and deal
with questions on computer
science, computers, and God.
And so I'm particularly happy
to welcome, today, Ray Kurzweil.
Ray Kurzweil is actually founder
of no less than four companies.
One is Kurzweil
Technologies Incorporation,
which is a consulting
firm, patent firms,
and other consulting issues.
The other one is Kurzweil
Education System.
Ray Kurzweil has invented
a couple of very innovative
technologies here.
In that company, he
distributes reading software
for blind people.
It is Kurzweil Applied
Intelligence Incorporation,
where he has invented
voice command software.
And finally, it's
Kurzweil Music System,
where he has invented a lot of
professional musicians' systems
for computers.
And so I was actually
impressed, already,
by that list of companies,
but was even more impressed
because his innovative
technology is not the only part
of why he is so much accepted.
But he's also very much
accepted within academia
because his contributions to
computer science and academia
are enormous.
And so he got no less than
nine honorary doctorate degrees
in science, and
engineering, and in music,
received numerous awards--
and I only mentioned two.
One is the Inventor
of the Year at MIT,
and the other one is that he
received the award for the Most
Outstanding Computer Science
Book of 1990 for his book
The Age of Intelligent
Machines, which was
published in 1990 by MIT Press.
I can highly
recommend that book.
It's very fun to read.
And he is currently working on
another book, which is called
The Age of Spiritual Machines.
And I'm very, very
happy that you are here
today to share with us the
thoughts about this book.
Welcome.
KURZWEIL: My wife is
annoyed that I skipped
the age of emotional
machines, but we'll
try to cover that as well.
It's a pleasure to be here
my old stomping grounds.
When I was a student
here, we had one IBM 1794
which was shared by
several thousand students
and professors.
You needed some influence to get
more than a few seconds a day.
And it ran at a quarter of
a MIP and had 32K of RAM.
Actually, core memory
it was back then.
So things have progressed
a bit, actually
in lock-step to
Moore's law, which
we'll talk a little bit about.
Let me start with a story that
some of you may recognize.
But I think for a lot of you,
it might be before your time.
"The gambler had not
expected to be here.
But on reflection,
he thought, yes, he
had shown some
kindness in his time.
And this place was even more
beautiful and satisfying
than he had imagined.
Everywhere there were
magnificent crystal
chandeliers, the finest handmade
carpets, the most sumptuous
foods, and, yes, the most
beautiful women who seemed
intrigued with their
new heaven-mate.
He tried his hand at roulette
and, amazingly, his number
came up time after time.
He tried the gaming
tables and his luck
was nothing short of remarkable,
winning game after game.
Indeed, his winnings were
causing quite a stir,
attracting much excitement
by the attentive staff
and by the beautiful women.
This continued day after
day, week after week,
with the gambler
winning every game,
accumulating bigger
and bigger winnings.
Everything was going his way.
He just kept on
winning and winning.
And week after week,
and month after month,
the gambler's winning
streak seemed unbreakable.
After a while this
started to get tedious.
The gambler was
getting agitated.
The winning was starting
to lose its meaning.
But nothing changed.
He just kept on
winning every game,
until one day, the now
anguished gambler turned
to the angel who
seemed to be in charge
and said that he
couldn't take it anymore.
Heaven was not
for him after all.
He had really figured he was
destined for the other place
after all.
And indeed, that's
where he wanted to be.
But this is the other
place, came the reply."
That's my recollection of an
episode of the Twilight Zone
that I saw as a young child.
Anybody here happen
to see that episode?
I think the title might
have been something like,
be careful what you wish for.
Or at least that's
what I would call it.
And as this engaging
series was wont to do,
it illustrated many of the
paradoxes of human nature.
We like to solve problems, but
we don't want them all solved.
Not too quickly, anyway.
We're more attached to the
problems than the solutions--
maybe to the process
of solving them.
Take death, for example.
A great deal of our effort
goes into avoiding it.
We make extraordinary efforts
to delay it and, indeed,
often consider its
intrusion as a tragic event.
Yet we would find it
hard to live without it.
Death gives meaning
to our lives.
It gives importance
and value to time.
Time would become meaningless
if there were too much of it.
If death were indefinitely
put off or even just put off
for a very long
time in human terms,
the human psyche would end up--
well, like the gambler
in the Twilight Zone.
Now, we don't yet
have this predicament.
We have no shortage today of
either death or human problems.
Few observers feel that the
20th century has left us
with too much of a good thing.
There is growing prosperity
fueled, not incidentally,
by information technology.
But the human species
is still challenged
with issues and difficulties not
altogether different than those
it has struggled with from
the beginning of our recorded
history.
The 21st century will be
different, in my view.
The human species, along with
the computational technology
that it initiated
the creation of,
will solve age-old problems
of need, if not desire.
And we'll be in a position to
change the nature of mortality
in a post-biological future.
I'll explain what I mean
about that a little bit later.
Now, do we have the
psychological capacity for all
the good things that await us?
Probably not, but that
might change as well.
Before the next century
is over, human beings
will no longer be the most
intelligent or capable type
of entity on the planet.
Now, as the abstract
pointed out,
let me take that
controversial statement back.
The truth of that statement
depends on how we define human,
and that will be a key
issue in the next century.
Unlike the 20th
century, the primary
political and
philosophical issue
will be the definition
of who we are.
But I'm getting a little
bit of ahead of myself.
To approach the 21st century, we
need to start from the present.
If we jump to the endgame, it's
a little unsettling and maybe
not quite believable.
But if we take it
step by step, I
think we'll see the inexorable
logic of the next century.
This last century has seen
enormous technological change
and the social upheavals
that go along with it, which
few pundits circa-1899 foresaw.
And the pace of change
is accelerating,
and it has been since the
inception of invention.
And as we will discuss,
this acceleration
is an inherent
feature of technology.
That's what makes
technology different from
just simply the use of tools.
There are a lot of
animals that use tools,
or at least there are
some, but those tools
don't evolve with time.
Our tools evolve.
The genes of that
evolution are really
our own knowledge base, which
we use to advance technology.
And that's an inherent
nature of technology.
And the result will be far
greater transformations
in the first two decades
of the 21st century
than we saw in the
entire 20th century.
But to appreciate
the logic of this,
we have to go back and
start with the present.
Now, computers today
exceed human intelligence
in a broad variety
of intelligence
yet very narrow domains, such
as playing chess, diagnosing
certain medical conditions,
timing buy-and-sell decisions,
guiding cruise
missiles, and so on.
Yet human intelligence remains
far more supple and flexible.
Computers are still
unable to tell
the difference between
a dog and a cat,
although I-- actually, I've
been saying that for years.
I think we probably could
program a neural net today
to make that distinction.
But computers can't tie
a pair of shoelaces,
they can't describe the objects
on a crowded kitchen table,
write a summary of a
movie, recognize humor,
or provide other subtle tasks
in which their human creators
excel.
Now, one reason for this
disparity in capabilities
is that our most
advanced computers still
remain far simpler devices
than the human brain
by a factor of
approximately a million,
give or take a couple
of orders of magnitude,
depending on what
assumptions you use.
But computers, as
is well known, have
been doubling in speed and
capacity or complexity--
which, it's important
to point out,
is actually a quadrupling
of computational ability--
every 18 months
since the inception
of calculating devices at
the beginning of the century.
And this trend will continue.
I'll come back to
Moore's law in a moment.
But if we extrapolate
that out, computers
will achieve the computing speed
and capacity of the human brain
by around the year 2020.
Now of course, achieving the
basic complexity and capacity
of the human brain
will not automatically
result in computers matching
the flexibility and range
of human intelligence.
The organization and
content of these resources
that is the software
of intelligence
is equally important.
And in a few minutes, I'll talk
about at least one scenario
that I think is credible
to achieve this.
Once a computer achieves a
human level of intelligence,
it will necessarily
roar past it.
Since inception, computers
have been far more powerful
than computers in
memory and speed.
The computer can remember
billions or trillions of facts
with extreme reliability,
can extract information
from billions of
items in a database
in a matter of seconds.
We're hard pressed to remember
a handful of phone numbers
or the directions to get here.
The combination of human-level
intelligence in a machine--
with the fact that
electronic circuits
are a million times faster
than neural circuits--
combined with the computer's
inherent superiority
in speed and
reliability of memory
will be a very
formidable combination.
Now as I mentioned,
electronic circuits
are a million times faster
than neural circuits,
so once a computer achieves
the human level of ability
in understanding
abstract concepts,
recognizing patterns, the
ability to read, for example,
it'll be able to apply
this ability to a knowledge
base of all human
acquired knowledge.
In fact, there's
a project in Kyoto
at ATR, Advanced
Technology Research
Laboratory, where
they're building
a billion neuron neural net.
And they plan to teach
it the ability to read.
And then we'll
basically set it loose
on all published human
literature, at least that's
available electronic form.
Now, a common reaction
to the proposition
that computers will seriously
compete with human intelligence
is to dismiss this specter based
primarily on an examination
of contemporary capability.
I mean after all,
when you interact
with your personal
computer, its intelligence
seems limited and brittle, if
it seems intelligent at all.
It's hard to imagine
one's personal computer
having a sense of humor,
or holding an opinion,
or displaying any of the
other endearing qualities
of human intelligence.
But the state of the art
in computer technology
is anything but static.
Computer capabilities
are emerging
today that were considered
impossible one or two
decades ago.
Examples include the ability
to accurately transcribe
normal continuous speech, which
all three leading companies
in speech recognition--
Dragon, my own company, Kurzweil
Applied Intelligence, and IBM--
recently demonstrated at COMDEX.
The ability to intelligently
respond to natural language,
to recognize patterns
in medical tests,
such as electrocardiograms
and blood cell
tests with an accuracy
exceeding human physicians.
And of course, to play chess
at a world championship level.
In the next decade, we'll
see translating telephones.
My company, Kurzweil
Applied Intelligence,
was recently acquired by
Lernout and Hauspie that has
language translation software.
And we're putting together
a translating telephone
with continuous
speech recognition,
text-to-text
language translation,
and text-to-speech synthesis.
And we plan to hold a
demonstration early in 1998,
where you'll be able to
call up somebody in Germany
and hold a conversation
in real time
with your speech translating
to German and vice versa.
In the second decade
of the next century,
it'll become increasingly
difficult to draw
any clear distinction between
the capabilities of human
and machine intelligence.
Evolution has been seen as a
billion-year drama that led
inexorably to its
grandest creation--
human intelligence.
The emergence in the
early 21st century
of a new form of
intelligence that
can compete with and,
in some arenas at least,
exceed that of
human intelligence
will be, in my view, a
development of greater import
than anything we saw
in the 20th century.
Now, this specter
is not yet here.
Computers today are still
a great deal simpler
than the human brain.
But with the
emergence of computers
that really rival and exceed
the human brain in complexity
will come a corresponding
ability of machines
to understand and respond to
abstractions and to subtleties.
Human beings appear to be
complex in part because
of their competing
internal goals--
things we call values,
emotions, represent and engender
subgoals that often
conflict and, in my view,
are an unavoidable
byproduct of the complexity
that is human nature.
As computers achieve a
comparable level of complexity
and as they are increasingly
derived from models
of human intelligence,
they too will necessarily
utilize goals that appear to
exhibit values and emotions--
of course, not always the
same values and emotions
that humans exhibit.
And a variety of philosophical
issues will emerge.
Are computers thinking or
are they just calculating?
Conversely, are human
beings thinking or are we
just calculating?
Presumably our brains
follow the laws of physics
so they must be machines,
albeit very complex ones.
Is there an inherent difference
between machine thinking
and human thinking?
To put it another
way, once computers
are as complex as
the human brain
and can match the human
brain in the subtlety
and complexity of thought, are
we to consider them conscious?
It's a difficult
issue to even pose.
Some philosophers feel it's
not a meaningful question.
Other philosophers feel it's
the only meaningful question
in philosophy.
And the question actually
goes back to Plato's time.
They had debates on
this issue, and imagined
machines of the complexity
of the human brain
made up of pistons, and
wires, and levers, and so on.
But as we actually have
machines that genuinely appear
to possess volition and
emotional responses,
this issue will become
increasingly compelling.
Now let's talk for
a moment about what
it will take to achieve
just the hardware
capacity of the human brain.
As is well known, computers have
been doubling in speed and also
the density of
computation, which
if you have a massively
parallel neural net
actually means you can put
twice as many neurons, run them
twice as fast, which is really
a quadrupling of the number
of neural connection
calculations
you can do per second,
every 18 months.
Computer memory today
is about a billion times
more powerful for the same cost
that it was when I was born.
And if the automobile
industry had
made as much progress in
the last half century,
cars today would cost
a hundredth of a cent
and go faster than
the speed of light.
Now, this exponential progress
is called Moore's law.
How many people here are
familiar with Moore's law?
I expect a lot of
hands to go up here.
Intel chairman Gordon Moore
first commented on this,
actually commented
in the mid-'70s.
He said it was 24 months.
In the mid-'80s, he
revised that to 18 months.
That's a corollary
of a broader law--
since nobody's claimed it,
I've named Kurzweil's law--
on the exponentially
quickening pace of technology
that goes back to the
dawn of recorded history.
I mean, not much happened
in, say, the 10th century
technologically speaking.
There may have been
one or two things.
In the 18th century,
quite a bit happened.
In the 19th century,
a lot happened.
And now in the 20th century,
we have major paradigm shifts
in a few years' time.
Now, some observers
have commented
that exponential trends
can't go on forever.
And we have lots of examples
of exponential trends
that go along and
then just hit a wall,
like a species happening
upon a new habitat,
is the classical example.
Its numbers will multiply
geometrically for a time,
and then it hits a
wall and may even
go in reverse when it exhausts
the supply in its new habitat.
But it would be highly premature
to predict the end of Moore's
law anytime soon.
The chip companies
themselves have
said they can
confidently foresee
20 more years of
Moore's law, just
using conventional approaches.
That alone is enough to put
the computational capacity
of the human brain into a
$1,000 personal computer.
Moreover, today's chips are
essentially flat with only one
layer of circuitry,
whereas the brain
uses all three dimensions.
We live in a
three-dimensional world.
Why not use all
three dimensions?
And circuits, particularly
superconducting circuits that
don't generate heat, will enable
the development of chips--
or I should say cubes--
with thousands of layers
of circuitry and also
smaller component
geometries, which
will multiply computing capacity
by a factor of millions.
There are more than enough
computing technologies
to assure the continuation
of Moore's law
for a very long time.
Now, the human brain has
about 100 billion neurons.
On average, they have about a
thousand connections from one
neuron to the next.
That's 100 trillion connections.
Each connection's
capable of a computation.
So that's a hundred
trillion-fold parallelism.
These circuits are very slow.
I mean, if we just copied the
human brain in electronic form,
it would run a
million times faster
because the neural circuits run
200 calculations per second.
Typical electronic circuits, 200
million calculations a second.
But 200 times 100 trillion is
20 million billion calculations
per second.
And that's about what
you get in the year
2020 in a $1,000
personal computer
if you just track Moore's law.
And again, the chip companies
feel that they can do that just
with conventional
approaches, not even
assuming things like crystalline
computers, and DNA computers,
and optical computers,
and quantum computers,
which is itself an interesting
subject because it's
a whole different
type of computation.
But I won't get
sidetracked on that.
Oh, and by the way, if
we were to harvest even
a fraction of the unused
computes on the internet,
and there are some
proposals for doing
that, we could create
virtual super computers
with the computing capacity
of the human brain today.
Now, as we achieve each new
level of hardware capacity,
new software technologies
become feasible.
And in fact, it becomes a
compelling economic pressure
to create software that matches
the hardware capability.
And one of the exciting
things about Moore's law
is, every time that
that screw turns,
whole new business
opportunities become available.
As I mentioned, continuous
speech with natural language
understanding is now feasible.
A product that Kurzweil Applied
Intelligence showed at COMDEX
recently, which got one of the
four best of COMDEX citations,
allows you to say things like,
I enjoyed my trip to Belgium
last week.
Make this paragraph
two points bigger
and change it's font to Arial.
I hope to go back
to Belgium soon.
And it actually figures out
that that second sentence
is a command, and
then carries it out.
And you can say the commands
in any way that you want.
These systems require
200 megahertz Pentiums
with 32 megabytes.
The point is that as hardware
capacity becomes available,
software capacities do follow.
And we will see
the same phenomena
with the full range of
human intellect, which
of course is comprised of many
different types of skills.
Now, there are a number
of convincing scenarios
we could discuss, but let me
concentrate on just one which
I find particularly
compelling, which is reverse
engineering the human brain.
I mean, the design is
right there in front of us,
and it's not at all impossible
to get at the information.
As the hardware capacity
to emulate the human brain,
20 million billion calculations
per second-- and that's
conservatively high.
I've seen other estimates that
are a thousand times lower.
But as that capacity
becomes available--
we're not there yet, but we
will be there in a couple
of decades--
projects to scan and understand
the algorithms of the brain
will be initiated.
In fact, that's
already been started.
Carver Mead's company,
Synaptics, basically studied
mammalian early vision--
the neural organization
of mammalian early vision
by looking at cat cortexes.
And by examining the typology of
the interneuronal connections,
the algorithms become apparent.
And it's not hard to see them.
Now, these are not conventional,
sequential Von Neumann
algorithms, these are not
all digital algorithms.
These are hybrid
digital-analog algorithms.
They're massively parallel.
They're not also conventional
neural net algorithms.
They're specialized
neural net algorithms,
but you can see them by
examining the topology
of the neural connections.
And they created a chip
that, in fact, duplicates
mammalian early vision.
Now, it's feasible, today,
to perform a destructive scan
of the human brain.
You could freeze a brain
and destructively scan it,
and see all of the connections
of someone recently deceased,
say.
Now we might not want to base
our templates of intelligence
on someone who's
recently deceased.
Better to catch someone
before they died.
Recently, a serial killer
agreed to be scanned
before he was executed, and
you can buy all 500 megabytes
of him on a CD-ROM.
This is available.
We may not want to base
our designs on the mind
of a serial killer, either.
But in terms of
noninvasive scanning,
magnetic resonance imaging today
can image individual somas,
or nerve cell bodies.
We can see individual
cells with today's MRI.
And the limitation of the
resolution and speed of MRI
is the speed of computation.
So as computers get faster--
MRI is a very computationally
intensive process--
our MRIs can be high resolution.
And in about 10 years--
in fact, the design of
MRIs now being designed,
which will be in the market
in four or five years,
can see the individual
connections.
The axons, dendrites, synapses,
and other neural components
that make up the
interneuronal wiring.
It will be feasible to
actually reverse engineer
these connections with
MRI in about 10 years.
Eventually, we'll
be able to resolve
the presynaptic vesicles
that many scientists believe
is the site of human learning.
Just as the Human Genome
Project is providing us
with the templates of
the human genetic system,
efforts to scan the neural
organization of the brain
will provide us with the
templates of intelligence.
And I will point
out that there was
a lot of skepticism about the
Genome Project 20 years ago.
And I mentioned this
project in ATR in Kyoto,
where they are in
fact now building--
expect to have this
in a couple of years--
a billion neuron neural net.
Implemented in hardware, not one
of these software neural nets.
And that's actually
pretty competitive with
the human brain right there.
Now let's talk a little
bit about the impact
of the emergence of a
thinking and feeling machine.
In this book The Age of
Intelligent Machines,
which I wrote 10
years ago, I predicted
that a computer would
be world chess champion
before the turn of the century.
And I went on to say
that when this happened,
we would either think
more of computers,
less of human intelligence,
or less of chess.
And if history was a guide,
we would think less of chess.
And indeed, that's
exactly what we're seeing.
Observers from Doug
Hofstadter, to People Magazine,
to Scientific American
have discovered
that chess is not so intelligent
and creative an endeavor,
after all.
Rather, it's really a matter
of brute force computation,
for which computers
are well suited.
But continuing to defend the
superiority of human intellect
in this way as we go through
the next couple of decades
will become
increasingly difficult.
A competition from intelligent
machines may seem threatening,
so one might expect constraints
of one kind or another
to be placed on this phenomenon
while the human species is
still in charge.
But while the overall phenomenon
may appear to be unsettling,
defining and implementing
any specific limitations
will not be at all
straightforward,
and I don't think
will be feasible.
The survival on Earth
of intelligent entities
that rival human thinking
is not an alien invasion.
Thinking machines are
humankind's own creation,
and evolution of tools intended
for our own productivity
and efficiency.
And indeed, we're
already enormously
dependent on our
intelligent machines, just
the contemporary genre.
If all our computers
were to cease operating,
society could hardly function.
The drive to add intelligence
and knowledge to our computing
devices is fueled by a
compelling economic incentive.
We've entered an
age of knowledge
in which the knowledge content
of products and services
is asymptoting to
100% of their value.
The enormous market
capitalization
of the computer industry--
one recent estimate put the
market cap of just Silicon
Valley companies started
in the last 10 years
at approximately $1 trillion.
And that's really where
most of the wealth today
is being created.
There was another
large figure from MIT,
but it was actually lower
than Stanford's number.
I'm not sure why that is.
Might be the warm weather there.
But a computerized
system that possesses
more flexible intelligence
and greater content
renders its
competition obsolete.
Stopping this
process would require
repealing this basic engine
of economic competition.
Now, it may appear that we have
full control of our machines
today, yet computers
already make
the majority of
buy-and-sell decisions
in our financial markets,
assemble products,
evaluate the work
product of human workers,
render medical
judgments and diagnoses,
guide airplanes, and conduct
a myriad of other tasks
on which we depend and by
which we are deeply affected.
And that's with
machines that are still
a million times simpler
today than the human brain.
When machines progress to be
as complex and ultimately more
complex than the
human brain, which
will happen in the next
century, our dependence
will only deepen.
This process is
gradual and ongoing.
It's a seamless progression
with no obvious discontinuities.
Now, computers don't yet
appear to be conscious players
in this drama.
No one wondered what
Deep Blue thought
of its own victory or Gary
Kasparov's press conference.
It's brilliant at playing
chess but it's otherwise
an idiot savant with
apparently little ability
to register opinions
or emotions.
No on worries today about
causing pain and suffering
to their computer programs.
But all of this will change,
not suddenly but inexorably,
nonetheless.
And we can address these
issues by simply assuming
that the human-machine
nexus represents strictly
an us-them relationship.
Remember that
computers are already
deeply embedded in the
grain of our civilization.
And this relationship will
ultimately become much more
intimate than it is today.
We have today artificial
skin, bones, joints, hearts,
blood vessels,
pancreatic implants.
So why not replace at least some
of our slow, unreliable, and
aging neural circuits
with faster, reliable,
synthetic ones?
We already have
cochlear implants.
Why not implants to
improve vision, memory,
and reasoning speed?
Why stop there?
These things sound
controversial.
Of course, there was an
article just in today's--
I think was today's
New York Times
that human cloning
was considered very
controversial some weeks ago
and now people are saying, well,
why not?
So views of these
things do change.
The computers of
the 21st century
will appear to have human-like
emotions because, in at least
some cases, their
designs will have
been derived from the reverse
engineering of human circuits.
And like humans,
they will have--
or at least appear to have--
spiritual experiences.
They will wonder, or at
least profess to wonder,
about the true nature of
consciousness and free will.
They'll wonder if
it's really possible
that humans are capable of being
aware of their own existence,
or if we only act as if we are.
And that's not adequate to
state that such developments
won't occur because of ethical
or political proscriptions.
The age of very
intelligent machines
will not be a single phenomenon.
Human ethics will
face a multiplicity
of slippery slopes.
Now, the advent of machines
that match and ultimately exceed
the full range of
human intellect
won't arrive on a single day.
It will be a seamless,
ever-accelerating progression.
And to get a feel for
how this will unfold,
I'd like to consider some
milestones along the way.
Now with the
impending millennium,
there are no shortage
of predictions
about what the next century
will be like, and futurism
itself has a long history.
Not a very impressive one.
One of the problems with
anticipations of the future
is that by the
time it's apparent
that these predictions
have had little resemblance
to future events, it's too
late to get your money back.
Fortunately, you didn't have
to pay for this lecture.
Let me start with a sampling
of some of the predictions
I made 10 years ago
about the 1990s.
Of course, I picked
out the better ones.
But if you buy the book,
you can see them all.
But in 1988, I wrote, "Computer
will defeat the world chess
champion before the year 2000,
and we'll think less of chess
as a result. There'll
be a sustained decline
in the value of commodities,
i.e. material resources,
with most new wealth being
created in the knowledge
contents of products
and services,
leading to sustained economic
growth and prosperity."
And interestingly,
Fed Chairman Greenspan
did recently acknowledge
that today's unprecedented,
sustained prosperity
and economic expansion
is due to the increased
efficiency provided
by information technology.
Occasionally you
read studies that
say that there's no
increase of productivity
from information technology.
The problem with these
studies is they factor out
the improvement.
They put it in both the
numerator and the denominator,
and say, we still only get
$10 of work done for $10.
And we only get an hour
of work done in an hour,
because we expect
to do a lot more.
There's no question that
productivity has increased.
In my companies, two people
can handle the operations
that used to require 15 or 20
people before we had computers
to organize these things.
But Greenspan is
really only half right.
He ignores the fact that most
of the new wealth being created
is, itself, comprised of
information and knowledge--
$1 trillion in
Silicon Valley alone.
Increased efficiency is
only part of the story.
"A worldwide information
network linking
almost all
organizations and tens
of millions of individuals,"
admittedly not by the name
World Wide Web.
"In warfare, almost total
reliance and digital imaging,
pattern recognition, and
other software technologies.
The side with the smarter
machines will win.
The vast majority
of commercial music
will be created on
computer-based synthesizers.
With the advent of widespread
electronic communication,
in the Soviet Union
uncontrollable
political forces
will be unleashed.
These will be methods far
more powerful than the copiers
the authorities have
traditionally banned.
The authorities will be
unable to control it.
Totalitarian control
of information
will have been broken.
Continuous speech
recognition for dictation."
Although, I did
have that in 1993.
So we were off by a few years.
"And then by the year 2000,
chips with over a billion
transistors."
So let me share
with you a sampling
of some predictions
for particular points
in time in the next century.
And these are predictions
I'm developing for the sequel
to the Age of Intelligent
Machines, which
is a book with the same
title as this lecture.
Start with 2009,
the computer itself.
"The majority of text is
created using continuous speech
recognition, but
keyboards are still used.
Also ubiquitous are LUIS,
language user interfaces,
using continuous speech and
natural language understanding.
Computer displays have the
display qualities of paper.
Chips are three-dimensional
with many layers of circuitry.
Supercomputers match at
least the hardware capacity
of the human brain.
Unused computes on
the internet are
being harvested, creating
human brain-capacity, virtual,
parallel supercomputers.
There's increasing interest in
massively parallel neural nets,
genetic algorithms, and other
forms of chaotic or complexity
theory computing, although
the majority of computes
of computers still use
conventional sequential
processing.
Research has been
initiated on reverse
engineering the human brain.
Education-- the
majority of reading
is done on displays, although
the installed base of paper
documents is still formidable.
Students of all ages routinely
have their own computer,
which is a very
thin slab weighing
about a pound with a
very high resolution
display suitable for reading.
Intelligent
courseware has emerged
as a primary means of learning.
Learning is becoming
a significant portion
of most jobs.
Learning at a distance
is commonplace.
Translating telephone
technology is commonly
used for many language pairs.
Telephone communication
is primarily wireless
and routinely includes high
resolution moving images.
Meetings of all kinds
and sizes routinely
take place with geographically
separated participants.
Haptic technologies allow
you to touch and feel objects
and people at a distance.
People have sexual
experiences at a distance
with other persons, as well
as virtual partners, business,
and economics.
Despite occasional corrections,
the 10 years leading up to 2009
has seen continuous economic
expansion and prosperity.
At least half of
all transactions
are conducted online.
Intelligence assistance--
which combine continuous speech
recognition, natural language
understanding, problem solving,
and animated personalities--
routinely assist with finding
information, answering
questions, and
conducting transactions.
A company west of
the Mississippi
and north of the Mason-Dixon
line achieves $1 trillion
in market capitalization."
I take no
responsibility for that
if you make
investment decisions.
"Political and social
issues-- privacy
has emerged as a
primary political issue.
The virtual constant use
of electronic communication
technologies leaves a
highly detailed trail
of every person's move.
There's a growing neo-Luddite
movement as the skill ladder--
i.e. the ladder,
level of skill needed
for meaningful employment--
continues to move upwards.
As with earlier
Luddite movements,
its influence is limited by
the level of prosperity made
possible by new technology.
The movement does
succeed in establishing
continuing education as a
primary right associated
with employment.
Musicians routinely jam
with cybernetic musicians.
Philosophy-- there's
renewed interest
in the Turing Test," which I
won't describe, but many of you
are familiar with it.
"Although computers
still fail the test,
there's greater
confidence that they
will be in a position to pass
the test within another one
or two decades."
This is a test for
seeing if computers
have human equivalents
in intelligence,
at least one proposed
by Alan Turing.
"There's increasingly
serious speculation
on the potential
sentience or consciousness
of computer-based intelligence.
The increasing
intelligence of computers
has spurred an interest
in philosophy."
Okay, now we'll jump to 2019,
about 20 years from now.
"The computer itself-- computers
are now largely invisible.
They are embedded everywhere--
in tables, chairs, desks,
clothing, jewelry, vehicles.
People routinely use
three-dimensional displays
built in their glasses.
Computer displays
create highly realistic
virtual, visual
environments overlaying
the real environment.
This display technology
projects images directly
onto the human
retina, and is widely
used regardless of
visual impairment.
Keyboards are rare,
although they still exist.
Most interaction with computing
is through physical gesture,
which computers respond to
both visually and physically,
and through spoken
communication.
Computers are facile with
two-way, natural language
communication.
People communicate with
computers the same way
they would communicate
with a human assistant.
Significant attention is
paid to the personality
of computer-based
personal assistants,
with many choices available.
Typically, people don't just own
one specific personal computer,
although computing is
nonetheless very personal.
The computational capacity
of $1,000 computing device
exceeds the computational
capability of the human brain.
Of the total combined computing
capacity of the human species--
i.e. all human brains--
together with the
computing technology
that the species has created,
more than 10% is non-human.
The majority of
computes of computers
are now devoted to
massively parallel
neural nets and
genetic algorithms.
Significant progress
has been made
in the scanning-based reverse
engineering of the human brain.
It's now fully recognized
that the brain is comprised
of many specialized
regions, with the typology
and architecture of the
interneuronal connections
varying widely depending on the
region's information processing
function.
The massively
parallel algorithms
are beginning to be understood.
To recognize that the
human genetic code does not
specify the sites in
interneuronal wiring of any
of these regions,
but rather sets up
a rapid evolutionary
process in which connections
are established and
fight for survival.
The standard process for wiring
machine-based neural nets
uses a similar genetic
evolutionary algorithm.
Education-- most learning
is accomplished using
intelligent virtual teachers.
To the extent that teaching
is done by human teachers,
the human teachers are often
not in the local vicinity
of the student.
The majority of
adult human workers
spend the majority of
their time learning
new skills and knowledge.
Communication-- you can do
virtually anything with anyone
regardless of
physical proximity.
The technology to
accomplish this
is easy to use and ever-present.
Routinely available
technology includes
high quality speech-to-speech
language translation
for most common language pairs.
Business and economics--
rapid economic expansion
and prosperity has continued.
The vast majority
of transactions
include a simulated
person, which
includes a realistic animated
personality and two-way voice
communication with high quality
natural language understanding.
Political and social issues--
people are beginning to have
relationships with automated
personalities and use them
as companions, teachers,
caretakers, and lovers.
Automated personalities
are superior to humans
in some ways, such as having
very reliable memories
and predictable personalities.
They are not yet regarded
is equal to human
in the subtlety of
their personalities,
although there is
disagreement on this point.
An undercurrent of concern
is developing with regard
to the influence of
machine intelligence.
There continues to be
differences between human
and machine intelligence,
but the advantages
of human intelligence
are becoming
more difficult to
identify and articulate.
Computer intelligence
is thoroughly interwoven
into the mechanisms
of civilization,
and is designed to be
outwardly subservient
to our apparent human control.
On the one hand, human
transactions and decisions
require, by law, a human
agent of responsibility,
even if fully initiated
by machine intelligence.
On the other hand,
few decisions are
made without significant
involvement in consultation
with machine-based intelligence.
Virtual artists
and all of the arts
are emerging and
are taken seriously.
These virtual artists,
musicians, and authors
tend to be associated with
humans or organizations, which
in turn are comprised of
collaborations of humans
and machines who have
contributed to the knowledge
base and techniques of
these cybernetic artists.
However, interest in the output
of these creative machines
has gone beyond the mere novelty
of machines being creative.
Visual, musical, and literary
art created by human artists
is typically a collaboration
between human and machine
intelligence.
The type of artistic
and entertainment object
in greatest demand continues to
be virtual experience software.
Philosophy-- there
are widespread reports
of computers passing the Turing
Test, although these tests do
not meet the
criteria established
by knowledgeable observers.
There is increasingly
serious discussion
of the subjective experience
of computer-based intelligence,
although discussion of the
rights of machine intelligence
is not yet in mainstream debate.
Machine intelligence is
still largely the product
of a collaboration of human
and machine intelligence,
and has been
programmed to maintain
a subservient relationship to
the species that created it."
Okay, we'll jump to 2029.
"Computer itself-- $1,000
unit of computation
has a computing capacity
of approximately 10,000
human brains.
Of the total combined computing
capacity of the human species
along with the
computing technology
that it initiated the creation
of, more than 99% is non-human.
The vast majority of computes
of non-human computing
is now massively parallel
neural nets, much of which
is based on the reverse
engineering of the human brain.
Many, but less than a
majority, of the specialized
regions of the human
brain have been decoded,
with their massively parallel
algorithms understood.
The number of specialized
regions numbering
in the hundreds is
greater than was
anticipated 20 years earlier.
Displays are now
implanted in the eyes,
with the choice of
permanent implants
or removable implants
similar to contact lenses.
Images are projected
directly onto the retina,
providing the usual
high resolution,
three-dimensional display
overlaid on the physical world.
Cochlear implants
originally used
just for the hearing impaired
are now ubiquitously used.
These implants provide both
auditory input and output
between the human user and the
worldwide computing network.
Direct neural pathways
have been perfected
for direct high bandwidth
connection to the human brain.
A range of neural
implants are becoming
available to enhance visual
and auditory perception
and interpretation,
memory, and reasoning.
Human learning is
primarily accomplished
using virtual teachers
and enhanced by the widely
available neural implants.
Automated agents are
learning on their own
without human spoon-feeding
of information and knowledge.
Computers have read
all available human
and machine
generated literature.
Significant new
knowledge is created
by machines with little
or no human intervention.
Human and non-human
intelligences
are primarily focused
on the creation
of knowledge in its myriad forms
and their significant struggle
over intellectual
property rights,
including ever-increasing
levels of litigation.
There is almost no
human employment
in production, agriculture,
and transportation.
The largest profession
is education.
There are many more
lawyers than doctors.
Computers appear to be passing
forms of the Turing Test deemed
valid by both human and
non-human authorities,
although controversy
on this point persists.
There's not a sharp division
between the human world
and the machine world.
Human cognition is being
ported to machines,
and many machines have
personalities, skills,
and knowledge bases derived
from the reverse engineering
of human intelligence.
Conversely, machine
intelligence-based neural
implants are providing enhanced
perceptual and cognitive
functions to humans.
There's growing discussion on
what constitutes a human being.
This is emerging as a
significant legal and political
issue.
The rapidly growing capability
of machines is controversial,
but there is no effective
resistance to it.
Since machine
intelligence was initially
designed to be subservient
to you in control,
it has not presented
a threatening face
to the human population.
Humans realize that
disengaging the now
human-machine civilization
from its dependence on machine
intelligence is not possible.
There is growing discussion of
the legal rights of machines,
particularly machines that
are independent of humans.
Although not yet fully
recognized in law,
the pervasive
influence of machines
in all levels of
decision making is
providing significant
protection to machines.
Although computers routinely
pass valid forms of the Turing
Test, there continues
to be controversy as to
whether or not machine
intelligence is
the equal of human intelligence
in all of its diversity.
The subjective experience
of machine intelligence
is increasingly accepted,
particularly since machines
participate in this discussion.
Machines claim to be
conscious, and these claims
are largely accepted.
They claim to have
as wide a range
of emotional and
spiritual experiences
as the human progenitors."
Okay, we'll jump
finally to year 2099.
"There's a strong trend towards
a merger of human cognition
and perception with the world
of machine intelligence, which
the human species
initiated the creation of.
The reverse engineering
of the human brain
appears to be complete.
The hundreds of
specialized regions
have been fully scanned,
analyzed, and understood.
Machine analogs are based
on these human models, which
have been enhanced and extended
along with many other massively
parallel algorithms.
These enhancements combined
with the enormous advantages
in speed and capacity of
electronic photonic circuits
provide substantial advantages
to machine-based intelligence.
There is ubiquitous use of
neural-implant technology,
which provides
enormous augmentation
of human perceptual and
cognitive abilities.
Humans who do not
utilize such implants
have difficulty engaging
in meaningful dialogues
with those who do.
There are machine-based
intelligences entirely derived
from models of
human intelligence,
although substantially
enhanced in terms
of speed and processing,
memory capacity,
and perceptual and
cognitive ability.
These intelligences
claim to be human,
although their
brains are not based
on carbon-based
cellular processes.
And there are many gradations
above these two scenarios.
The concept of what
it is to be human
has been significantly altered.
The rights and powers of
different manifestations
of human and machine
intelligences
and their various
combinations represent
a primary political and
philosophical issue."
Well, let me end this
lecture with just a couple
of philosophical
mind experiments.
And these are experiments
that philosophers
have thought about,
actually, long before we
had the computational technology
to even conceivably implement
these mind experiments.
Well, consider the statement,
I am lonely and bored.
Please keep me company.
Now, if your computer
displayed that on its screen,
would that convince
you that your notebook
is conscious and has feelings?
Well, clearly no.
It's rather trivial
for a program
to display such a message,
and presumably the message
comes from the human
author of the program.
The computer is just a
conduit for the message,
much like a book or
a fortune cookie.
Suppose we had speech
synthesis, and the computer now
speaks its plaintive message.
Have we changed anything?
Well, we've added some technical
complexity to the program,
and some human-like
communication means,
but we still don't regard the
computer as the genuine author
of the message.
Suppose now that the message
is not explicitly programmed,
but it's produced by a
game-playing program that
contains a complex model
of its own situation.
This specific message
may never have
been foreseen by the human
authors of the program.
It's created by the
computer from the state
of its own internal model as it
interacts with you, the user.
Are we getting closer to
considering the computer
as a conscious, feeling entity?
Well, maybe just a tad.
But if we consider
contemporary game software,
this illusion is
probably short lived
as we run up against
the limitations
behind the computer's
ability for smalltalk.
Now suppose the mechanisms
behind the message
grow to become a massive
neural net built from silicon
but based on the reverse
engineering of the human brain.
Suppose we develop
a learning protocol
for the neural net that enables
it to learn human language
and model human knowledge.
Its circuits are a million times
faster than human circuits,
so it has plenty of time to
read all human literature
and develop its own
conceptions of reality.
Its creators don't tell it
how to respond to the world.
Suppose now that it
says, I'm lonely.
At what point do we
consider the computer
to be a conscious agent
with its own free will?
And what exactly do
these words mean, anyway?
This has been, really, the most
vexing problem in philosophy
since the Platonic
dialogues illuminated
the inherent contradiction
we have in these terms.
Let's consider
this slippery slope
from the opposite direction.
Our friend Jack-- circa
sometime in the 21st century--
has been complaining
lately of some difficulty
with his hearing.
A diagnostic test
indicates he needs more
than a conventional hearing aid
so he gets a cochlear implant.
Once used only by people with
severe hearing impairments,
these implants are now common
to correct the ability of people
to hear across the
entire sonic spectrum.
The surgical procedure
is successful,
and Jack is pleased with
his improved hearing.
Is this still the same person?
Well, sure he is.
People have cochlear
implants today, in 1997.
We still regard them
as the same person.
Now Jack is so impressed with
the success of his cochlear
implants that he likes
to switch on the built
in phonics-cognition circuits.
And these circuits
are already built in,
so in case he
decides to use them
he doesn't need another
insertion procedure.
So by activating these
neural replacement circuits,
the phonics-detection nets
built into the implant,
bypass his own aging
neural-phonics regions.
His cash account is
also debited for use
of this additional
neural software.
And again, Jack is pleased
with his improved ability
to understand what
people are saying.
Do we still have the same Jack?
Of course.
No one gives it
a second thought.
Jack is now sold on the benefits
of this emerging neural-implant
technology.
His retinas are working okay
so he keeps them intact,
but he decides to try
out the newly introduced
image-processing
implants and is amazed
at how more vivid and rapid his
visual perception has become.
Same jack?
Why sure.
Jack notices that
his memory is not
what it was as he struggles to
recall names, and the details
of earlier events, and so on.
So he's back for
memory implants.
Now, these are amazing.
Memories that had grown
fuzzy over the years
are now crystal clear.
Some he would have preferred
had remained fuzzy.
Still the same Jack?
Well clearly, he's
changed in some ways.
And his friends are impressed
with his improved faculties.
But he still has the same
self-deprecating humor,
the same silly grin.
Yep, it's still the same guy.
So why stop here?
Ultimately, Jack will have the
option of scanning his entire
brain and neural system--
which is not entirely located
in the skull--
and replacing it with
electronic, photonic circuits
of far greater capacity,
speed, and reliability.
There's also the
benefit of keeping
a backup copy in case anything
happens to the physical Jack.
Now certainly this specter is
unnerving, maybe amusing, maybe
more frightening than appealing.
And undoubtedly, it will be
controversial for a long time,
but just keep in mind how
long human cloning was
controversial.
And according to the
exponentially growing pace
of technological
change, a long time
will not be as long
as it used to be.
But ultimately, the
overwhelming benefits
of replacing unreliable neural
circuits with improved ones
will be too
compelling to ignore.
At some point-- and if
not in the 21st century,
then most likely in the next--
there will be Jacks
who go all the way.
Have we lost Jack
somewhere along the line?
Jack's friends think not.
Jack also claims he's the
same old guy, just newer.
His hearing, vision,
memory, reasoning ability,
perceptual ability
have all improved,
but it's still the same Jack.
Now we could we could extend
this scenario and mind
experiment in many
different ways,
but I'd like to leave
some time for discussion.
So let me just touch on
one other issue, which
is to put aside the
continuity of consciousness
and just consider
the fundamental issue
of the existence of
consciousness itself.
How do we know that
it exists at all?
I really only have
one data point,
which is my own consciousness.
I am conscious.
I have experiences.
I have emotions.
I can infer that I exist.
This is Descartes's
famous dictum.
And although it's
been interpreted
as a symbol of Western rational
philosophy which describes
fundamental reality to the
physical world, Descartes's
simple statement is
just this, I think--
i.e.
I have conscious
experiences-- therefore, I am.
Therefore, I exist.
But I also know that I'm not
the only conscious entity
in the world.
Or do I?
Actually, I have no
evidence for this,
but I assume it to be
the case, as otherwise it
would be difficult to
maintain my sanity.
And I say this in
the first person
because that is where
I have to start.
But what evidence do I have
that other people are also
conscious?
Well, maybe after an
hour of this lecture,
I am the only conscious
person in this room.
But I maintain that the evidence
is not scientific evidence
at all because it's not
a scientific question.
We can, of course, correlate
certain expressions
of conscious experience
with certain patterns
of observed neural
functioning, and there
is research along these lines.
But that does not
constitute scientific proof
for the subjective
experience of another entity,
even if that entity is a person.
From the thought
experiment at the beginning
of this discussion--
i.e.
The computer says I'm lonely--
we know that an
entity claiming to be
having a particular experience
is not proof that it is so.
Not only might the entity be
having a different experience
than it's claiming to have, it
might not be conscious at all.
Now I assume, and I
assume we all assume,
that other people have
conscious experiences somewhat
similar to mine because they
are convincingly displaying
behaviors that are similar
to my own behaviors
when having certain experiences.
In other words, if I
see somebody crying,
I assume they're having an
experience similar to ones
I've had when I felt sad and
displayed a similar behavior.
But despite my
empathetic reaction,
there's no direct way to measure
the subjective experience
of another person.
Now, although we humans all tend
to assume that each other is
conscious, as we move away
from shared human experience,
human views of this issue begin
to diverge quite radically.
For example, the issue
of animal consciousness--
are animals conscious
creatures making decisions
and experiencing feelings?
To many humans,
including this speaker,
it seems apparent
that this is the case.
Again, based on this
empathetic perception
of animals displaying
behavior similar to my own.
But opinion on this
is far from unanimous.
And if we disagree on
the subjective experience
of animals, then
we might conclude
that there's far greater
opportunity for disagreement
when it comes to the subjective
experience of machines.
So far it doesn't seem
like much of a debate.
With our machines still
a million times simpler
than the human brain, their
complexity and subtlety
is comparable to
that of insects.
But as we've talked about,
this philosophical debate
will become far less abstract
as the next century unfolds.
We will have Jacks who
have indeed replaced
and supplemented some--
and eventually, someday--
all of their neural circuitry
with electronic
photonic equivalence.
Conversely, we'll
have computers that
have been derived, in part
or in whole, from scans
and reverse
engineering of humans.
And there will be many
variations and combinations
of these scenarios.
So who and what is conscious?
When is the professed
feelings of an entity
to be taken at face value?
And when is it to be regarded
as a programmed response?
When is destruction of an entity
to be considered destruction
of property, and
when is it murder?
When do we have to be
concerned about causing
pain and suffering to
our computer programs?
In the 21st century,
this polite debate
of the last two
millenniums will become
the primary political struggle.
And how will this
issue be resolved?
In my view, the outcome
will favor the machines.
First, recall that many of us
are convinced that animals have
their own subjective life,
as a result of our noticing
behaviors in animals that are
similar to those in humans.
This phenomena will actually
be stronger with regard
to machines of the 21st
century because these machines
will be based, in large
part, on human designs.
They will appear
very familiar to us.
And as the above
scenarios point out,
they will indeed
claim to be human--
to be your old
friend, to be Jack
even if instantiated in an
electronic, photonic substrate.
Second, the machines will
be part of the debate.
They will be sufficiently
persuasive to profoundly
influence the discussion.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thank
you, Ray, so much
for this provocative and
fascinating view to the future.
So I guess there
are some questions.
I could imagine, do you
take the question, or--
KURZWEIL: Questions,
comments, flames?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, flames.
KURZWEIL: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is
probably a bit off topic,
but it concerns the economic
side of these classifications
so that's [INAUDIBLE]
stop me, now.
But I think it deserves
at least brief comment.
You said in one of
your predictions
was that essentially no
human beings were working
in agriculture in
30 years, and that's
what most human beings
are working on now.
Which brings me to
my question, what
are all these
other people doing?
KURZWEIL: Well actually,
in the United States,
we've already gone through that.
We had 40% or so
of our population
working in agriculture in 1900.
Today it's 3%.
Well, I mean, we've
survived that transition.
We're undergoing a
similar transition now
in production
labor in factories.
But within a few
years, the percentage
of the population actually
working assembling products
in factories will be under 5%.
I mean, this is the
challenge of the Luddites.
In the late 18th century, when
these textile machines started
coming out and one person
could do the work of 10
with a machine, it
was just obvious
that employment
was on its way out.
It would just be
had by an elite.
What we've actually seen-- if
you look at, say, the last 100
years, when most of human
automation has taken
place-- is we've gone
from, in the United States,
12 million jobs in 1870
to 130 million jobs
today from applying something
like 25% of the population
to almost 60% of the population.
And the jobs are at
a much higher level.
And a lot of the new
employment is, in fact,
in education to
provide the higher
level of education required.
And that's the skill
ladder that I referred to.
We're adding jobs at the
top of the skill ladder,
and removing them at the bottom.
And a lot of the new
employment is in education
to provide those skills.
And so far, the human race has
been able to keep up with that.
And jobs today are
more interesting,
they pay eight times as much
in constant dollars today
compared to 1870.
So so far, it's been a very good
thing because the challenge is,
what happens--
I mean, can we keep pace
with that indefinitely
as the skill ladder moves up?
I don't know.
PROFESSOR: Can we have a--
AUDIENCE: I kept hearing
lots of [INAUDIBLE]..
It appears that some
notion that understanding
humans' identity, or
personality or even entity
will be obsolete to some degree.
Like if you have entity,
is that completely
independent from the substrate?
Already you have
multiple backups
that issues physical
immortality, they just go.
Looked But what happened?
As you were saying, you
can modify your identity
very rapidly?
Once in a while, you
will experience what
I would call death forward.
It's modification
beyond recognition.
So the physical
substrate lifespan issue
would be replaced with the
identity lifespan issue.
Also, if you have complete
memory of your experiences,
you can do funny things
like personality rewinds.
And if you have a distributed
fluid architecture that
is global, what
you can do, you can
employ multiple sensors,
actuators, and the processes
for a cognitive task
on a contractual basis,
and then dissolve
the whole thing.
So it's hard to say what
exactly is an entity once--
what needs to be preserved,
like much of it goes.
PROFESSOR: Can I have
you repeat the question?
[LAUGHTER]
KURZWEIL: Well, the question
has to do with what constitutes
the identity of a person.
You used the word
entity, but I think
that's what you were getting at.
And it's the issue
that I'd started to get
into at the end of my remarks.
It's an issue we could
talk a long time about.
I mean, there are two
schools of thought.
One is that we are
these particles,
and that's what I am.
And the other school of thought
is, I'm not the particles
at all, I'm the pattern.
It's like the shape that
you see in a stream.
If you see water
rushing around a rock,
you see a certain shape.
And that shape could
remain constant for hours,
but in fact the particles are
changing every few milliseconds
as the water rushes through.
Now, there's a stronger
argument for the pattern
than there is for the
particles because, in fact, we
are like the eddy in a brook
because our particles are
constantly changing.
We change most of our
cells every few years.
Not nerve cells, but
even in nerve cells
we change the
particles that comprise
the cells every few years.
I mean, every two
or three years,
we're a completely
different set of particles.
But it's in, at least, a
continuum of the same pattern.
So that would argue
for the pattern.
But you could make a strong
counter-example for that.
If you scanned somebody, you
now have that information.
And then you instantiated the
person in a new substrate.
And the person walks out and
thinks it's the same person,
but the old person
is still there.
And that old person thinks
he's the same person,
and in fact, may
not even be aware
that you've ever instantiated
a copy of him somewhere else.
And that would tend to
contradict the pattern
argument.
So it is a real
dilemma, and that's
why it's been a vexing
philosophical issue.
AUDIENCE: The
essential premise I
gathered was that with all
these extra supercomputing
capabilities, we'll be able
to emulate intelligence
by replacing or reverse
engineering brain
circuits with newer circuits.
My question was actually
posed a hundred years ago
by Swami Vivekananda,
and I'd like
to pose it-- he posed
it better than I could.
And what he said was this.
"There is a big
discussion going on
as to whether the
aggregate of materials
we call the body is the cause of
the manifestation of the force
we call the soul,
thought, and so on,
or whether it is thought
that manifests this body.
The religions of the
world, of course,
hold that the force called
thought manifests the body,
and not the reverse.
There are schools
of modern thought
which hold that that
which we call thought
is simply the outcome
of the adjustment
of the parts of the machine,
which we call the body.
Taking the second
position-- that the soul,
or the mass of thought, or
whatever we may call it,
is the outcome of this machine,
the outcome of the chemical
and physical combinations
of matter making up the body
and brain--
leaves a question unanswered.
What makes the body?
What force combines the
molecules into the body form?
What force is there
which takes up
material from the mass
of matter around it,
and forms my body one way,
another body another way,
and so on.
What makes these
infinite distinctions?
To say that the force
called the soul is
the outcome of the combination
of the molecules of the body
is putting the cart
before the horse.
How did the combinations come?
What force was
there to make them?
If you say that
some other force was
the cause of these combinations,
and the soul, which is now
seen to be the mind of the
particular mass of matter
is itself the result of the
combinations of these material
particles-- it is no answer.
That theory ought to be taken,
which explains most if not all
of the facts, without
contradicting other existing
theories.
It is more logical to say
that the force which takes up
the matter that forms the
body is the same, which
is manifested to that body."
KURZWEIL: Well, let me
repeat the question.
But I think it's a
good example of how
this issue has been considered
long before computers
were evident.
There are really, again,
two schools of thought.
The Western school of thought
is that the fundamental reality
is stuff, matter, particles.
And that they swirl
around and evolve,
and eventually evolve
intelligent entities that
are conscious.
The view that's
been, say, associated
with Eastern thought is
that the fundamental reality
is consciousness--
not matter or particles--
and thought, which is a
manifestation of consciousness.
And that matter is what we
have to be conscious of.
And essentially, we
start with consciousness
and then create matter as a
projection of consciousness.
It's interesting that
in the 20th century,
Western science has
come around to ascribing
a fundamental reality
to consciousness
because in quantum mechanics,
particles do not decide where
they're going or
even where they have
gone until they are forced to
do so by a conscious observer.
And there's a fundamental
reality to consciousness.
And so we do see a blending
of these two schools.
AUDIENCE: The examples you
gave of reverse engineering
basically talk about
measuring electrical signals
or visualizing what's
going on in your brain.
You're sort of localized.
But how about non-local
processes like--
well, consciousness
as I understand
it is hard to localize, but also
the brain, as I understand it,
also produces
hormones, which get
into your circulatory system
and affect your whole body.
And I don't see how you're going
to ever electronically model
something like that.
KURZWEIL: Well, the
endocrine system
is certainly tied in strongly
to our neural system.
The chemical messengers
are very strongly
influenced by the
endocrine system.
And that's the whole genesis
of mood altering drugs,
such as Prozac, and so on.
But those processes are not
actually nearly as complex
as the neural process itself.
And there's no
reason why they can't
be emulated as well, to the
extent that we want to emulate
them or need to emulate them.
As for consciousness
being not a local process,
we don't really know
what consciousness is.
I really don't think it's
a scientifically observable
process.
But it is true that human
cognitive processes are not
localized.
They are more like
holographic processes.
Our memories are
based on the patterns
of connections in a region.
And that's the essence
of neural net processing.
I mean, that's not
inherent to human beings.
It is quite different than the
way most computers work today,
which is sequential and
logically organized.
Our sequential
rational functions,
which are in the cortex--
which is the folded up
two-dimensional surface,
which is a fairly late
evolutionary development--
is a very small part of
our neural processing.
Most of the human processing
is pattern recognition,
which is highly distributed.
But we can emulate that
in machines as well.
And a lot of the
anti-AI backlash
is really focused on
just symbolic processing,
which is one technique,
which is a valid technique.
But we won't get to emulate
many types of intelligence,
particularly the whole area
of pattern recognition,
by just using
sequential processing.
And I had an interesting
discussion with Murray Campbell
of the IBM Deep Blue team.
That is because the Deep
Blue is an ultimate example
of sequential processing
taken to an extreme.
And the computer builds
up this massive tree
of move and counter-moves.
And at the end, it finally
has to evaluate [INAUDIBLE]
position, and it does that
with a grab bag of rules
that they've just
hand-tuned, which is fairly
much a hodgepodge of rules.
And I said, why don't you
replace that with a neural net?
And you can train the neural
net on every master game that's
been played in
this century, which
they have on their hard drive.
And he thought that
was an interesting idea
and started to work on that, but
then they canceled the project.
But it is possible, actually,
to use both types of techniques.
PROFESSOR: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: In your evocation
of reverse engineering,
you mention a
number of strengths
that would be gained by
implementing algorithms derived
by human processing in machines.
Presumably, if we did that,
lacking a perfect human
to do it, we'd also implement
pathologies of thought
in machines.
Have you considered
the implications
for machine pathologies?
For example, socio-pathologies
that might in fact lend them
less of a benevolent picture--
which in the
benevolent synthesis,
which you have depicted.
KURZWEIL: Well, there are
many different scenarios.
We wouldn't necessarily
want to copy one person
unless, in fact,
that's what we're
intending to do-- is to capture
a particular personality.
But the primary scenario
I was articulating
was not just to scan the
information in a dumb way--
which is basically
what we've done today
with the genetic code.
We have the entire
human genetic code.
Actually, we'll have
in about 12 months.
But we don't understand it.
It's kind of a machine code.
And we're trying to
do a disassembly of it
and understand the source
code, but we don't know
what the source language is.
But what we really would like
to do with the genetic code
is understand it.
And what we would like to
do with the interneuronal
connections is to really
understand the algorithms.
Now, the one example I
gave of Carver Mead's work,
they've done exactly that.
They looked at the connections,
and they were actually
able to figure out what
the algorithm is and then
implement that in silicon.
It's very clever work.
And that's really the primary
thrust of my argument, which
is, we will find that
there are hundreds
of different
specialized regions.
The brain is not one tabula
rasa, just one big neural net
that organizes itself.
There are very highly
specialized regions that deal
with vision, or
hearing, or music,
memory, different kinds--
emotional regions.
And each of these have
different structures
that are highly
specialized for their task.
And it certainly will
be a great benefit
to understanding human
behavior, to actually begin
to understand how
the brain works.
And I believe that
will be feasible.
And you don't necessarily have
to see every single connection
because in these
early vision circuits,
it's very highly repetitive.
So after you've
seen 50 of them, you
don't have to see all
50 million circuits.
So we'll gain a lot of
insight into human behavior.
And we'll also learn some
intelligent algorithms
that we can then apply
to computer problems.
PROFESSOR: Can we
have one last flame?
You choose.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering about
your picture of the computers
as being pretty subservient--
designed to serve
man, and all that.
And my impression
is that if you get
a really intelligent
machine, you have
to give it a lot of autonomy.
The way you get information
from [INAUDIBLE] and you
got into it.
Keeping a machine
like that subservient
may be possible, but I--
KURZWEIL: I never said that
they're subservient, I said,
apparently subservient.
I said, apparently subservient.
AUDIENCE: Okay, but
anyway, I respect
that they may try to
make legal terms so
that we won't let machines
be completely autonomous.
So you'll have to have this
human interface so that someone
is going to take
responsibility for it,
but I don't think
it's practical.
I suspect that we'll get very,
very intelligent machines that
only be very autonomous,
and the question
of whether we want to
give them human rights
is going to be extremely
moot, and we won't decide.
It will be decided
by the machines.
PROFESSOR: Would you mind
repeating that question?
Repeating the question for the--
KURZWEIL: Well,
the question dealt
with whether or not machines
would remain subservient,
and whether or not we'll want
to give them human rights.
And then pointed out
that they won't really
be necessary since they
won't really care about that.
I think computers will provide
a benevolent and subservient
face.
But that could be
as much a tactic
as a strategy or a reality.
It is the case, generally, that
the more intelligent organism,
or species, or civilization,
or the civilization
with the superior technology
has generally been dominant,
for better or for worse.
So whatever intelligence
is a form of power.
Knowledge is power.
And machines will have
the power consistent
with their capability.
But again, it's not
an us-them nexus.
I think human beings--
we will enhance our
abilities through this type
of technology, and we will
be part of that future.
It's a combined
civilization, really
which ultimately will merge
human and machine capabilities.
Thank you very much.